herzlich willkommen zu einem video unter
dem die kommentare zu 90 prozent so
aussehen werden es ist das jahr 2016 sex
ist man darf nicht sagen ob frauen
attraktiv findet oder nicht sie schon
ein aufschrei durch die reihen gehen auf
ganz youtube das ist dann wahrscheinlich
wieder ein sexistisches video und bittet
mich einfach alle späteste jetzt schon
sdxc ism getippt haben versucht erst gar
nicht weil ich für jedes mal dass jemand
sexismus oder sexistischen die
kommentare tipper aus dem fenster
springen werde
wir legen los mit dem scheiß video aber
bevor wir loslegen leute erstmal danke
danke danke danke unser merch store ist
richtig richtig krass ab dann nach 24
stunden hatten wir vom baby blue tun
asics s&m ausverkauft was richtig krass
ist nach unter 24 stunden glaube ich war
das sogar jetzt haben wir vor allem noch
diese wunderschönen shirts lag damit im
black wings ins tor und natürlich noch l
und xl comex danke danke danke für alle
bestellungen bisher und check auf jeden
fall noch mal die t-shirts und die
puhdys ab diesen auch richtig richtig
richtig gut geworden
davon gibt's noch ein paar stück auch
nicht mehr so viele deswegen auch da
schnell sein so natürlich an wen denkt
man wenn man ein video macht die drei
heißesten youtube
anna katja krasavac als allererstes aber
die werte dame hat ihren account jetzt
auf privat gestellt bei 646.000
abonnenten auf privat gestellt
versteht ja auch privat gestellt damit
leute nicht sehen was sie da macht ist
646.000 abonnenten bike hat er das
gemacht hat kommen heute keine bilder
von ihr dran sondern von allen möglichen
anderen youtube in aus deutschland und
ich habe hier schon mit ganz ganz ganz
ganz feine sammlung rollenbild von leoni
habe ich auch mutter gefragt was denkt
ihr was sind in euren augen heißt
youtube in deutschland und ihr habt
geantwortet und ich freue mich richtig
auf eure antwort schon mal was was sie
so geschrieben habt ok haben doch eine
antwort heißt es you tube rennen in
deutschland weiblich karl es heute keine
sorge das kann passieren
jeder versucht sich mein geschlecht und
helden übels aufgepumpten bodybuilder
mit so einem bad in solchen bizeps für
eine frau
das kann passieren aber in nächste
kommentar wird bestimmt besser ich bin
richtig gespannt zu lesen hier konkreter
geschrieben falun gong crafter der
nächste wird sollte dass man einfach nur
zwei echt blöde kommentare habt ihr
wirklich gute vorschläge gemacht oder es
sogar der erste sinnvolle vorschlag da
die von leer die krawalle mir doch mal
vor ihr ein bild 1 von david kong dollar
spannung und die gute schon 30 jahre alt
alles klappt da gibt es eventuell
personen die der widerspruch einlegen
würden da die 30 jahre alt aber der
natürlich mehrere fotos deswegen jetzt
wo der nummer 2 auch ein ganz großes
highlight irgendwie ist immer die hälfte
ihres gesichts verdeckt auf den fotos
aber vielleicht jetzt mehr als deutlich
jünger ist überhaupt nicht verwerten sie
bekommen aber okay da g super hast du
gut gemacht gott likes linkes auge und
die nase bekommen aber da geh du musst
noch den dritten test bestehen denn ich
habe mir heute drei fotos von mir
ausgesucht ich habe heute leider kein
foto für dich
darf ich sogar drei fotos für die
aktivierende leichte veränderung die sie
im gesicht diesem bild
[Musik]
ja dafür dass es eigentlich halb und
halb mensch ist ist die hunde magier und
b k alles klar aber noch einige andere
vorschläge gemacht zum beispiel kam die
freundin von mir ist es von marcel
scorpion glaube ich so nie lübz mit sony
habe ich jetzt nicht all zu viele
persönliche erfahrung gemacht wissen
einmal in köln im taxi zusammen gefahren
deswegen zu nehmen unsere persönliche
geschichte weil ich lange ich hoffe
trotzdem dass du gut abschneide das
jetzt hier alte haus komme runter
peter frau okay das ist das ist schon
mal relativ sieg damit hat sie dagegen
auf den ersten schlag komplett
outperform 22 und gott like auf diesem
bild wenn die kammer hatte nicht
geschaut aber auch sehr wichtige info
die guten haben schon die
weihnachtsbeleuchtung dahinten
aufgehängt dieses bild habe ich und was
bereichert jetzt weiß ich dass bei
marcel scorpion und soll die looks die
weihnachtsbeleuchtung hängt mein leben
bereichert aber so what kospi garten
foto for you know you back from you das
ist es dass banker foto wenn man sein
die faust seinen kindern verschwinden
lässt soll ich das aber probieren auf
innsbrucker bilder
ich habe im letzten mal lust bekommen
bei dem letzten video vielleicht soll
ich das mal probieren dass ich erst mal
so ein bisschen skin lorsch ebenso und
dann die hand aber so dran bleibt okay
aber wir noch eine größere auswahl der
kamera geht wirklich zu neige deswegen
jetzt go go go go go als nächstes wurde
von euch vorgeschlagen berliner sophie
das finde ich jetzt aber unfair
warum bekommt die nur ort ist will ich
jetzt echt anfährt ist betrifft nicht
persönlich otto k punkt auch okay das
kümmern muss schaut daher aber noch ein
foto von ihr weiß eigentlich was
germany's next topmodel will doch etwas
anschauen schreibt nicht in die
kommentare was ich sowieso nicht
interessiert nächstes bild von medien
also familie hatte nur zwei chancen
heute stand immer noch ganz ehrlich
melina wenn du das siehst ist das
garantiert nicht
wir sind wir sind einig verstehst du wir
sind ein bisschen falsch aber wir teilen
dasselbe schicksal auf haut punkt wir
sind beide und was bei attraktive
menschen aber diese verdammte software
will uns einfach nur spanien geben
das ist nicht in ordnung okay wir haben
aber noch eine person hier und zwar ist
das niemand geringeres als die deutschen
nicki minaj darf man auch sagen
deutschen nicht im nachschuss eigentlich
keine beleidigung die rede ist
selbstverständlich von shirin damit
relativ heftiges close up youtube ist
ein toller job youtuber ist wirklich ist
und ob man muss hier bilder in hohhot
puncto hochladen und dann wenn die eine
bewertung bekommen muss man so tun als
wird ein die bewertung irgendwie jungen
in irgendeiner hinsicht studien david
gratuliere dir zu gott like soll kurz
anrufen nein ich habe mich nicht okay
ich glaube heute ziemlich scheiße aber
ich finde ich ganz geil denn wir haben
hier nochmal shearing david zum letzten
mal als letzter wird von heute
wenn du jetzt nochmal gotteshaus jackpot
über es hat mich immer noch nicht aber
an dieser stelle trotzdem einen
riesengroßen applaus sharing du hast es
geschafft du hast es auch mit an der
kamera vorbei schon geschafft leute ich
sag jetzt mal einfach nur eine sache wie
es nochmal diese dieses vorkommen aus
pokémon go was man immer aus den eiern
bekommen hat und was man total scheiße
fahren leute mit diesem kleinen
denkanstoß verabschieden wir ins
wochenende
morgen kommt die erste folge war morgen
kommt die erste folge waren ich hoffe es
wieder durch spaß macht bis zum nächsten
mal haut rein macht's gut